Yo ! Bienvenue dans ce nouvel et  premier épisode du Coup de Phil'
Alors, qu'est ce que le Coup de Phil' ?
C'est des poadcasts vidéos
qui ont pour but d'initier à la philo
mais d'une manière un peu plus fun que d'habitude
et comme c'est la première vidéo
Et peut-être la dernière, ça va dépendre de son succès
On va traiter quelque chose
qui est fondamental en philosophie
c'est l'Allégorie de la Caverne
par Platon
Coup de Phil' !
Première question :
C'est qui Platon ?
Le chien de Mickey ?
Euh, une planète du système solaire ?
Euh..euh, un poisson. Le thon qu'on aplati ?
Un plat thon ?
Platon, c'est le disciple de Socrate
et Socrate, c'est un peu
L'inventeur de la douce philosophie
Platon, c'est un philosophe de la Grèce Antique
et comme tous les philosophes, il s'est attaqué à pleins d'idées et pleins de concepts
Avant même d'attaquer tout ça
Il se demande : Mais c'est quoi une idée ?
Donc qu'est-ce qu'un concept philosophique après tout ?
Est-ce que un étron ( e-tron) ne serait pas un tron électronique ?
Je ne sais pas
Et là, il se rend compte d'un truc
Même si toute notre vie, on a vu un lit en bois
Et bien, si on nous montre un lit en métal
On va reconnaître que c'est un lit !
Eh ouais, mon gars !
Alors que, quand on nous a expliqué pour la première fois ce que c'était un lit,
on ne nous a pas dit toutes les sortes de lits possibles
Et pourtant, on reconnaît un lit quand il est différent du sien !
Du coup, heureusement qu'on a des idées, quoi !
Vous imaginez, genre, un monde sans idées
Oui, bonjour !
Je m'appelle Marcel et je vous appelle pour une erreur sur votre catalogue
Bah, en fait, dans la section lit
l'article "Fluk", il est en métal et non en bois
Bah...Euh... C'est pareil quoi !
Un lit, c'est en bois
Bah, je vous en prie. Merci, au revoir.
Hé Georgette ! J'ai encore fait une bonne action, hein !
On est tous dans ce monde réel sensoriel
Avec des idées qui sont identiques à chacun
Mais il y a une question qui se pose
Et là, Platon
Pour lui, les idées elles viennent
du monde des Idées
En fait c'est un peu comme s'il disait... Euh
Dans ton cul !
Mais en mode Antiquité
Donc, c'est pour ça que le caca est l'idée la plus importante...
- Platon !
- Quoi, Polystyrène, quoi ?
- Elles sont où, les idées, en fait ?
- Elles sont dans le monde des Idées, voilà !
Elles sont dans le mondes des idées !
Voilà...
On peut revenir sur le caca, maintenant ?!
Ça intéresse quelqu'un, le caca ?
En fait, à la naissance, notre esprit avant d'arriver dans notre corps, il passe par le
Dans le monde des Idées, il y a l'idée parfaite de lit, qui coexiste avec l'idée parfaite de chien, qui coexiste avec l'idée parfaite de stylo.
En passant par le monde des Idées
L'esprit s’imprègne de toutes les idées parfaites
L'idée parfaite de lit, de chien, de stylo
Mais aussi de...
Liberté, égalité, fraternité
Et quand il arrive dans le corps à la naissance
Bah, du coup, il a déjà toutes les idées en place
Ouais, mais s'il a déjà les idées en places, euh...
Il sait déjà tout alors le gars !
Moi, quand je suis né, j'savais pas tout moi, t'as vu !
Excellente remarque !
En fait, les idées, elles sont déjà là mais on n'en a pas conscience
Vous avez jamais eu cette sensation où on vous explique un truc
Et en fait, vous avez juste l'impression que l'on vous le rappelle
Et que vous le saviez déjà
Ça m'est jamais arrivé, ça
Ça, pour Platon, ça s'appelle la
Mais c'est quoi le rapport avec la caverne, t'as vu ?!
En fait Platon symbolise tout ça avec l'image d'une caverne
En gros, on serait tous là avec des chaînes
En face d'un mur, dans le noir, tous ensemble !
Attends, genre, des grecs, des grecs
Ensemble dans une soirée, là
Hein, dans la caverne
Et personne ne se doute de rien ?
c'est bon, je suis pas un teubé
Et sur le mur, on verrait des ombres
Parce que derrière nous, il y a une grosse lumière qui fait mal aux yeux
Et entre nous et la lumière
Des gens qui passent avec des objets
Par exemple un stylo
Et ce stylo !
Ce stylo, c'est l'idée parfaite de stylo
Ce qui est projeté sur le mur c'est juste une ombre de cette idée parfaite
Et c'est ce que nous on voit en fait au quotidien
Bah oui, ce stylo, là, par exemple que je tiens
Là dans ma chambre, dans le monde réel
C'est que l'ombre de l'idée parfaite de stylo
Pourquoi c'est pas l'idée parfaite du stylo ?
Bah, déjà parce qu'il est bleu
Alors que l'idée parfaite de stylo n'est ni bleu ni noir ni rouge ni quadricolore
quadricolore
- Ah c'est pas mal !
- Parce que y a quatre couleurs primaires
Quadricolore
- C'est pas mal
- Y a quatre couleurs, ils sont quatre couleurs
quadricolore !
C'est pas mal ça ! C'est joli ça !
Donc ça c'est juste une ombre de l'idée parfaite du stylo
Donc nous, on serait là
on verrait des ombres
qui sont, en fait, ce que l'on voit dans la vie réelle
et derrière nous
Il se passe la vraie action avec les idées parfaites, les concepts, etc.
Du coup, pourquoi on ne se retourne pas pour aller voir ce qu'il se passe ?
Parce que mon gars !
Dès que tu te retournes, genre, t'as tellement de lumière dans la gueule
Ça fait trop mal aux yeux !
Sauf une personne !
Où ça les idées ?
Ceux qui arrivent à se retourner et à regarder les idées en face
Ce sont eux, les philosophes !
Alors pour que ce soit un peu plus clair parce que c'est un peu chaud
Je vous ai mis un schéma pour, peut-être, mieux comprendre
Nous, on est là, prisonniers, dans la caverne
Et on voit des ombres de formes d'objets
Ici, c'est le chemin pour aller au monde des Idées
Donc on voit que les philosophes sont dans ce chemin
Et là en haut, on voit le monde des idées
Donc, là où il y aurait l'idée parfaite de chien, de lit, de stylo par exemple
Et pour accéder au monde des Idées ça se fait par un seul chemin :
J'espère que pour vous l'Allégorie de la Caverne est maintenant un peu plus claire
C'était le premier épisode
D'un Coup de Phil' !
On se retrouve une prochaine fois !
Pour un prochain épisode !